le samedi matin la place Maubert
ressemble à la rue Catinat de Saigon de
tout Paris et même de banlieue les
Vietnamiens viennent pour faire leurs
achats chez tan bean où l'on trouve tout
ce qui s'entassaient naguerre sur les
étals des marchés saigonnais
[Musique]
au détour d'une rue près de la Place
d'Italie dans un quartier moderne de
tours et de galerie marchande l'Asie est
là malgré le froid de février mélange du
Vietnam du Cambodge avec un peu de Hong
Kong pour le décor ultra moderne les
couleurs les odeurs les affiches les
magasins les visages
[Musique]
chassé par la guerre qui continue
expulsé par les régimes communistes
fuyant les massacres ou les camps de
rééducation plus de 100 000 indochinois
ont trouvé refuge à Paris les
Vietnamiens sont les plus nombreux et au
lieu de se disperser dans toute la
France ou dans toute la capitale ils ont
préféré se regrouper dans de petits
îlots comme celui-ci ou l'atmosphère
qu'il recréer les aides à oublier l'exil
[Musique]
le marchand de disques était commerçant
à Vienne le patron d'un restaurant
parlementaire au Cambodge le bijoutier
importateur de pièces détachées à Saïgon
ils ont leur magasin leurs immeubles
leurs associations leur journaux ils
vivent ensemble conservent leurs
traditions parlent leur langue tentent
de faire venir leur famille c'est chaud
long ou Saigon reconstitué sur les rives
de la Seine
[Musique]
pourquoi Paris parce que certains
parlaient un peu le français parce que
d'autres avaient déjà de la famille ici
parce que l'Amérique n'en a pas voulu
parce que beaucoup avaient dans un coin
de leur mémoire le souvenir du temps ou
Paris était la métropole
[Musique]
monsieur levant low quel était votre
métier à Saigon
assez
[Musique]
je suis
entrepreneur de contribution
et après
moi et mes amis nous avons une chaîne de
cinéma de Naftal moi personnellement je
regrette beaucoup d'avoir quitter notre
pays mais
sur les régimes de communistes et vous
avez eu l'idée d'installer une salle de
cinéma asiatique
vos films viennent de rencontre oui nous
avons importé directement dans Hong Kong
et de formation comme les films qui
passaient à Saigon avant 75 et pourquoi
vous êtes-vous installés dans ce
quartier particulièrement parce que
avant nous avons étudié
dans ce quartier nous avons vu il y a
beaucoup de vietnamien qui s'installe
ici surtout dans le quartier du 13e
c'est pour ça
au cinéma
à côté du cinéma une bijouterie deux
artisans dans la boutique qui exécutent
sur leur les commandes ou les
réparations des bijoux importés de
Bangkok où fabriqués sur place une
clientèle exclusivement vietnamienne
c'est là que travaille monsieur lin
après avoir quitté le Vietnam sur un de
ses bateaux rafistolets qui traversent
la mer de Chine et quelquefois il sombre
la femme de Monsieur lin et vendeuse sa
mère tient la caisse et Monsieur Lind
tente de faire venir des frères des
cousins pour s'agrandir et pour
reconstituer ce type d'entreprise
familiale qui faisait la fortune des
commerçants saigonais oui des copains
des voisins des
camarades mais je peux pas venir faire
venir vos compagnies c'est difficile
parce que là-bas on sort chaque personne
pour demain un visa de sortie il faut
pailler de l'or
à votre avis essayez encore beaucoup de
Vietnamiens qui souhaitent quitter le
pays bien sûr même
tout et non pas moyen
c'est-à-dire et non pas de l'or pour pas
y est le gouvernement communiste
le gouvernement actuel communiste là et
organiser le bateau pour exporter des
hommes pour avoir de pièces de leur par
personne
communiste lui-même qui organise des
départs
pour avoir de 10 pièces de la
[Musique]
place Maubert dans le 5e arrondissement
c'est l'un des plus anciens quartiers
vietnamiens de Paris les boutiques les
restaurants existent depuis 20 ans 30
ans
[Musique]
le samedi matin la place Maubert
ressemble à la rue Catinat de Saigon de
tout Paris et même de banlieue les
Vietnamiens viennent pour faire leurs
achats chez Ethan bean où l'on trouve
tout ce qui s'entraîne à guerre sur les
étals des marchés saigonnais fruits
légumes riz soja paté boulettes tout
cela vient de Bangkok donc de Chine ou
bien de Marseille ou encore des cuisines
familiales des émigrés qui fournissent
ce haut lieu de l'alimentation
vietnamienne
[Musique]
il n'est sans doute pas un Vietnamien
attendant un visa dans les camps de
réfugiés thaïlandais ou Malet qui ne
connaissent l'adresse de la place
Maubert
[Musique]
c'est place Maubert que Madame coin se
fournit elle habite depuis trois ans
Pierrefitte prête Paris avec son mari et
ses deux enfants deux pièces dans un SLM
d'une cité administrative
de philosophie à Saigon a installé
l'hôtel des ancêtres dans un placard en
contreplaqué la photo de son père
entourée des bustes de Voltaire et de
pasteur
comme les commerçants les intellectuels
vietnamiens n'ont plus leur place dans
le nouveau régime et pour éviter la
déportation dans ces zones économiques
où l'on meurt de fièvre il a préféré lui
aussi émigrer ce n'est pas par politesse
mais par comparaison qu'il déclara
apprécier la vie à Paris une vie qui a
été pourtant au début bien difficile
pour cet ancien universitaire
mais si je travaille bien je gagnais
bien différents
au Vietnam avec comme minute travail
beaucoup mais gagner pas beaucoup quel
métier avez-vous fait quand vous êtes
arrivé en France un Camara arrive en
France je travaille dans
usine fort 10 jours et après à Bordeaux
et je monte à Paris je travaille dans
Hôtel Bénin
comme pour
après pendant deux ans
après
9 mois
je suis chômage
mais maintenant je travaille je fais
journal dans mon journal je vous dis
avec tous les biennamiens il faut
ensemble pour contre communiste
et communiste
comment avez-vous été accueilli en
France quel a été l'attitude des
Français quand vous êtes arrivés
en France le gouvernement français aide
de nous beaucoup
on nous aide la maison
et
on nous donne chaque mois
900 francs pendant 9 mois et après je
travaille
et les vos voisins est-ce que vous avez
fait des vous avez vous avez des amis
français maintenant oui
institutrice il me fait à l'école jolie
opérer
étudier les enfants français chaque jour
elle aide les enfants à prendre le
français
il y a 3 ans ont aujourd'hui à l'école
complètement rattraper les petits
français de leur âge
est-ce que tu continues à parler le
vietnamien
oui
et qu'est-ce que tu préfères tu préfères
parler en français ou parler en
vietnamien
pourquoi
tu es mieux
parce que tes petits camarades parlent
français à l'école
qu'est-ce qui te plaît ici
[Musique]
dans la banlieue sud de Paris à Bagneux
les bons de la pagode Anne de Saigon
viennent d'inaugurer une nouvelle salle
de prière
était au temps des Américains considérés
comme procommuniste car les bons
s'opposaient au régime de Dieu qui
violaient les droits de l'homme mais pas
plus que les intellectuels ou les
commerçants les religieux disent-ils ne
peuvent aujourd'hui vivre librement à
Hô-Chi-Minh-Ville
le vénérable tous les mines a passé
trois ans en prison avant de réussir à
s'enfuir depuis l'arrivée des normes
vietnamiens il continuait à militer pour
la liberté de prier la liberté de penser
la liberté de parler
exilé à Paris les bouddhistes ankouan ne
désarment pas il continue à dénoncer
sans cela c'est le régime qui les a
chassés nous ne faisons pas la politique
mais comme d'autres fois et maintenant à
l'étranger aussi nous au contenu
de tous nos efforts pour défendre les
droits de l'homme
parce que nous pensons que
si il n'a pas la liberté de croyance il
n'a pas la liberté de l'homme il n'a pas
le droit de l'homme
c'est la raison que nous à l'étranger
continue on nous efforts pour la
défendre les droits de l'homme
chaque semaine à Bagneux ont pris pour
les disparus les baux de people les
jeunes tués au Cambodge les prisonniers
politiques et surtout on se souvient on
se souvient inlassablement de cette
ville qui ne s'appelle plus à
[Musique]